e successa una cosa simpatica molto
simpatica se mi state chiedendo
ovviamente tutti i rockets league libri
non so più parlare ci sono le mode di
rocket league sono finissime e ci sono
le cose belle tipo spronare miliardo di
persone facciamo 50 verso 50.000 lo
sapete o mio dio per recarmi canicani
che sta lasciando tutto la madonna dei
gesù ragazzi volevo fare una intro
decente io niente
c'è ovviamente ci sta avere la madonna
che tiro ti sparano 50 giocatori tra
l'altro difficoltà al massimo gigi ma
devo parlare comunque io madonna che
bordello praga la guerra mondiale è
scuro siamo in 200 turbo diturbi many
fottono tutti papas al passato porca eva
ce n'era uno giustamente perché sono in
duemila figura inserisce a 1 caracas
la cosa divertente provare a segnare se
metti la difficoltà al massimo che
questa anche loro si trovano difficoltà
a giocare contro loro stessi grazie al
pene la nostra forza e questa devi
insegnargli la devo dire che se siamo in
50 diventi un deficiente
dall'altra parte non riesco neanche a
toccare il pallone tifosi lai di e
togliti o solo quando quando sono fuori
dalla marmaglia un
minima possibilità di toccarla però è
veramente minima c'è un turbo brutto
pezzente uno ce n'era stata sostengono
quando il palo quello è scemo 5 ed è
impossibile far gol ve lo giuro
impossibile 50 non si può segnare non
puoi segnare è un
un ammasso di gente ci prova da lì
tirate ho segnato io ho passeggiato io
come ho fatto
come ho fatto se che con uno tra l'altro
perché erano in duemila voglio rivederla
fabio quanto larghe per rivedere un blog
nora galaga veramente non mi ha fatto
neanche rivedere gol talmente la java
non mi ha fatto rivedere il gol ok già
così già così che confronta prima di
niente già così giocabile figurati in
cinquanta ragazzi veramente in 50 anni
se poi tutti volano se volassero tutti
sarebbe una roba veramente atroce
vabbè allora facciamo una roba decente
burqa e gol
credo sia gol solo che non gli della
madonna quando segnano un casino
penso che sia gol solo che non gliel'ha
dato perché disabilitato il gol fatto a
bergamo ok
credo che il fatto di spararle 50 sia
stato un po una pisciata fuori dal vaso
però maver gol abbiamo preso gol noi non
si sa come non accalcate vi tanto non
segno non vi dal punto non vi accalcate
se e border ok go demonio o demolito
qualcuno come ho fatto
saliamo la palla va bene ok questo
potrebbe essere un problema
non entra neanche nella porta la palla
minuscola oddio non libero grazie
gentilissimo ma riesci anche solo a
toccare la palla è un genio non la vedo
neanche dove dove dov'era
non è che mi sta ma non la vedo neanche
ma dov'era eccola parco schifose non la
prendi neanche se vuoi dirmi che la
palla di prima è rotolata semplicemente
importa dove eccola ho segnato ieri che
riesco a farmi autogol non puoi segnare
perché la palla non entra nella porta di
fantastico cioè per niente tra l'altro
non entra nella porta ballarò era ora
[Applauso]
credo che mi sia che lasciato il gioco
però cui ne sono sicuro va bene allora
facciamo che io faccio il boss in sta
partita orca vacca non posso volare
perché sono troppo pesante fermi tutti
ci sono che non lo faccio che cosa fatti
crederci ma mai ci avrei pensato di
segnare così è andata di purissimo ma
posso anche farle diventare più piccole
del normale le macchine tipo 0.9 abili o
mio dio mio dio fermi aiuto
cosa non vedo non vedo neanche cosa
stanno facendo quelli siete scemi anno
riuscì e tu lo si tocca la palla o a
piece of the facile toccare la palla non
è facile madonna quanto è difficile
stare fermi tutti sono strane le
macchine piccole prove
vabbè proprio per una partita seria
praga 5 minuti di partita così la voglio
vedere vi prego ci ha messo un'ora per
seta possiamo ripartire adesso per
favore di tutti parco demonio 2 a 0 dai
raga non posso perdere la partita
montata contro le boat maledizione beh
va beh cosa è successo lì carrarmati
dalla guerra mondiale fortissimo che
call of duty funzione ok non riesco a
toccherà fammela toccare fermi fermi
ok porca vacca preso il ballo perché era
buona ecco l'ho toccata di nuovo ormai
sono diventato un fenomeno legato e
perché loro l'ha toccato gli ha tagliato
la togli la tagliata ammazzo non uno che
sappia giocare non un odio mia possiamo
perdere 5 o non posso mettere questo
video su youtube perdo 5 1 contro i
botti e niente è finita 1 a 5 o un pelo
cambiato le regole del gioco visto che
non segnavamo mai proviamo così
sicuramente è meglio neanche a parte che
un cubo non è una palla incubo ma va
bene toglietevi che devo segnare io
anche nella mia porta sticazzi resto a
toccare la palla ha capito la palla e il
cubo
porca vacca se la palla era normale se
fosse stata ormai possiamo mentre la
grandezza normale per favore almeno con
la bottiglia introdotti dentro la sede
da soli siete da soli la guerra
l'ho toccata io ma mai una volta che ma
una volta nella vita che cio culo o
incredibile ma guarda guarda pietro
lercio siamo riusciti a prendere con noi
poi sono riusciti a prendere gol dai
maledizione buttata là dentro lightman
due minuti mancano laida ed eccolo posso
giocare
no ad aregai mi rifiuto veramente vi
prego almeno prima di due minuti
buttarla dentro
fatemi vincere una partita prima di
concludere vi dà meno una una sola né
che vi chiedo tanto una sola no nel
mondo nome la scocca
siamo riusciti a segnare nella nostra
persona riuscita a fare un assist
incredibile proprio per segnare nella
nostra porta perfetto eccolo eccolo raja
pietro lercio 23 23 bye bye grande rush
no cambia porta gremio e l'altra porta
l'altra porta a 30 secondi ci credo e ci
credo ci credo tantissimo su credo
tantissimo
vi prego sempre secondi qualcosa tutti
dai la guerra tra incisi con da dieci
non è vero ma dai
e la vincolo così grandi ragazzi sempre
così vi voglio carichi e stato
bellissimo giocare con voi mi sono
divertito tantissimo e la prossima volta
prima farlo online perché in teoria
queste cose non le puoi fare online
però se giochi con degli amici in teoria
puoi farlo quindi ragazzuoli spero che
vi sia piaciuto così tanto mi piace
ancora iniziati i lavori si chiede non
ci vediamo da ragazzo
[Musica]